okay mr speaker
uh youtube is rolling
okay
thank you mr clerk i called the uh rules
committee
to water on this session june 3rd 2020
and recognize the clerk for a message
thank you mr speaker mr speaker you have
a script that you are prepared
to read and if if so would you
please do that certainly thank you
as chair of the house rules committee i
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor
as a result of the cobia 19 pandemic in
accordance with the governor's emergency
audit number 12 pursuant to executive
order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen could
contemporaneously to this meeting which
was authorized pursuant to the
government's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that we are
a providing public access to the meeting
by telephone with additional access
possibilities
by video and other electronic means we
are utilizing zoom
for this electronic meeting all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff of the ability to communicate
contemporaneously
during this meeting through this
platform
the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by clicking on the following
website
address http s
colon backslash backslash zoom
dot u s backslash j
backslash nine three eight four
nine three six eight seven zero
nine or dialing one of the following
phone numbers
one three one two six
two six six seven nine
or 1-929-205-6099
b providing public notice of the
necessary information for accessing
accessing this meeting we previously
gave notice to the public
uh the asses of the necessity
of necessary information for accessing
this meeting
including how to access the meeting
using zoom or telephonically
this information is printed in the house
calendar c
providing a mechanism for the public to
alert the public body during the meeting
if there are any problems with access if
anybody has a problem
please call two seven one three six
zero zero or email at h
c s at l
e g period s t a t e
period n h period
u.s d adjourning the meeting if the
public is unable to access
this meeting in the event the public is
unable to access
access this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
paul smith house clerk is the meeting
host
chris conquest speakers executive
assistant
additional house committee service staff
providing support are
brad greenland christina dyer
gen 4 and pam smalling this is a public
meeting of the rules committee
a copy of the agenda in minutes has been
posted
on the main page of the general court
website
under the heading remote meetings quote
unquote
please note that all votes that are
taken during the meeting shall be done
by a roll call vote let's start the
meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room
with you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know
law i now call on the flirt to take the
committee attendance
thank you mr speaker mr speaker we did
seem to lose
representative holzel i do see that
there are some numbers
on the call-in line and i'm not sure if
one of those is her
uh if so i would ask her to raise her
hand uh so she does
um uh
so she does
notify us that it's her so okay
uh shirtless i am at the
uh the speaker's office at the state
house and i am alone
walner
you're muted i'm sorry i'm at my home in
concord new hampshire
and i am alone
weber i'm at my residence in malpul new
hampshire and i am alone
lay i am at my residence in jaffrey new
hampshire and i
am alone ebel
i'm at my residence in new london new
hampshire and i'm alone
butler i'm at home in hart's location
and i'm alone inch
i'm at my office in merrimack and i am
alone
packard i'm in the uh
state house and i am alone proposal
i do not see that she's raised her hand
mr speaker so i'm not sure if she is one
of those callers or not
baldusaro i'm at my home in londonderry
and my wife is in and out
mr speaker we we do have a quorum of the
committee
with nine of 10 members having answered
the rule and
uh we are attempting um to reach
representative fossil
okay very good um we'll continue with
the first
item on the agenda which is the approval
of the minutes of february 8
2020 and while staff is attempting to
contact
representative holzel and get her back
online with us
is there a motion to approve the minutes
of february 18th
to move representative sarah moves is
there a second
i'll second representative walner
seconds the motion is there any
discussion
seeing none uh the last clerk to call
the role
on the acceptance of the minutes of
february 18 2020.
yes walner yes
weber
represent weber
yes say
yes yes
butler yes
inch abstain i wasn't present
packard yes
well the sorrow yes
motion carries eight to zero mr speaker
thank you mr clerk
the first item on our agenda for this
morning is to discuss an approved
amendment to house rule 65
parentheses a as introduced by myself
representative shirtless
at this time i'm going to turn the cable
over to the vice chair representative
mary jane walner
um for as we take up this bill for the
purpose of my presentation as well as
the vote
um and i asked the chair for recognition
to speak to my motion thank you mr
speaker
and i recognize you for your motion
thank you
madam chair um as we know
in this pandemic the house went into
recess um
in mid um mid-march
and have not been able to really
continue with our work in a timely
manner
right now our rules required
uh right now we're out of rules we do
not have rules to finish out the rest of
this session
the amendment i'm offering is an
amendment to uh house rule 65a
what the amendment would do would be to
uh have june 11 2020 as the last day to
act on all house bills
june 25th 2020 would be the last day to
report all senate bills
and june 30th 2020 would be the last day
to act on all senate bills
and last day to concur on amended house
bills
those are the rules that i would like to
see this committee
authorize me to introduce and to
give approval to draft legislation if
there's any questions i'd be glad to
answer them
madam chair of representative hinch has
his hand up
representative hinch uh thank you madam
chair
um i'd like to be recognized for
comments
on tuesday march 17th i received an
email from
the speaker's chief of staff with
details
for your committee on legislative
continuity
the duties of the committee were to
investigate any necessary
legislation change in house rules or
possible constitutional amendment
the committee met once briefly over the
phone
a subsequent meeting was canceled and no
other meetings
of the continuity committee have
occurred we had a chance to meet work on
these issues
identify priorities and build consensus
within our respective caucuses
based on the committee's bipartisan work
it appears
as if the process was abandoned and you
made decisions exclusively with your
leadership team
and told us what you decided to do or
not to after those decisions had already
been made
this was not how this was supposed to
work when republicans supported the
change to
to rule 65b it was with the
understanding
that you were acting in good faith and
would include republicans
in this crisis response process it was
with the
understand that understanding that you
would proactively seek
republican input to achieve the
concurrence required
in 65 d we have seen very little attempt
at seeking republican input via the
community
committee and rather than work within
the terms
of 65b we now cnn run around it by
proposing this amendment
65a mr speaker we have a number
concerned about the proposed schedule
in your 65a amendment it sets forth a
very quick time
frame for public hearings we are not
fully briefed on how these hearings will
occur
but we can only assume at this point
they will be remote
as we all know the house held its first
remote public hearing
on a bill yesterday and there were
several concerns brought to my attention
about its extended time to complete
function
and execution how can we reliably
administer dozens
of these hearings in a short time frame
republicans have a road map forward we
have a realistic and comprehensive
set of dates for deadlines that we
believe meets the needs of a thorough
legislative process
we are not here to obstruct we agree
that the people's work needs to be
addressed
but we are here to ensure the spirit of
bipartisan cooperation
the spirit of 65b is not pushed aside
during this pandemic i think we all know
where this is going mr speaker
perhaps if the continuity committee
meets sometime in the future
we can work these things out rather than
be presented
with an all-or-nothing vote on one
party's proposed dates
respectfully mr speaker i will not be
voting
in support of the amendment 65a thank
you mr speaker
i thank the leader for his message thank
you representative hinch
um actually uh could i have a motion
on the on these uh proposed rules
changes
representative evil so moved
representative evil moves to accept the
uh rules changes
is there a second representative lay has
his hands up madam vice chair
okay representative lay seconds a second
um
further discussion on um the motion
yes representative lay uh thank you
um yeah i i actually i support the rules
uh
change um and i just wanted to offer
some comments
um in response to my colleagues comments
my understanding of the legislative
continuity committee
uh was that the legislative continuity
committee was to
deal with long-range issues involving
uh processes of the house in particular
uh things such as constitutional
amendments etc
there was never any understanding that
the legislative continuity committee was
actually
a committee to arrange bipartisan
agreement on policy issues
that was not the intent of that
committee and actually in the letter
that um
or in the email that the uh my good
friend just read
there's no mention of any sort of uh
policy issues to be discussed
nor was there on the floor of the house
um at the time nor is there in rule 65b
having said that um there was con
consultation with
um members of of of my good friends uh
uh party um and i would just simply note
that um
of the fifth of the 20 uh policy
committees
that um uh i i would consider here
two made no recommendations in terms of
bills but of the remaining
uh 18 uh three committees
okay did not there did not seem to be
much consultation but that means and
15 of the 20 committees there was
consultation between the committee chair
committee vice chair and the ranking
member
and on eight of those committees there
was extensive
uh communication between the ranking
member
and the committee chair so much so that
the ranking member contributed to
in many cases the completion and the
development of the so-called priority
bill list
so the notion that there's been no
consultation is a false claim
to also claim that there has been no
communication between
uh the democratic leadership and my
friend's uh
leadership as well is also a false claim
i would i think or at least a mistaken
claim i will say that i i take back it
is not a false claim it is mistaken
um because i believe that there has been
uh repeated communication between the
speaker
um and members of my good friend's
leadership team
so to make these sorts of accusations
and claims is simply uh
an error i believe um which i hope my
friend will correct
thank you thank you representative lay
um further discussion uh representative
hinge
thank you um i would i don't want to get
into a debate on this that's not going
to be productive at all for us
but i would call uh representative lay's
attention to the
exact verbiage of house rule 65
that talks specifically about the
deadlines
listed below will be reasonably amended
by the speaker
with the concurrence of the democratic
and republican leaders
we are here talking right now about
deadlines scheduling and that's exactly
what my
remarks referred to thank you
thank you representative further
discussion
see no further discussion um i will ask
the clerk to call the role
the motion is um to accept the rules
amendment as presented by steve
by uh uh representative shirtless thank
you man of vice chair uh walner
yes weber yes
lay yes evil
yes butler
yes inch no
packard no
the motion passes five to four
uh mr mr clerk just for the record uh is
the person
presenting the motion not entitled to
speak
not your vote rather mr chairman um as
as is your policy when when a member is
presenting something before the
committee
and they are uh the person presenting
they typically do not
participate in the vote um if if you'd
like to change that
we can we can certainly no that's fine i
just want to put it on the record why
could i represent weber seems to have a
question
in our policy committees
my understanding is that that has never
been the rule um and i don't know of any
policy committee that has operated that
way
it has always been the procedure ever
since i started here
uh that the committee
chair stepped down from presiding
when they were presenting a bill and the
vice chair or another member presided
but no one has ever to my knowledge
lost their vote for presenting a bill
and i think if we this is representative
weber is correct mr speaker uh i think
that's a very dangerous precedent so
i hope that we will not observe it now
and i hope we will not observe it going
forward because it's a complete
misstatement of what we've been doing
the representative weber's is correct mr
speaker i i misspoke
on that when we spoke yesterday i was
under the impression that you
uh were stepping aside from the vote but
uh um certainly if you
uh want to vote then by all means uh i
have not stated the
uh the vote total yet so um
would you i'll pass on this vote
mr clerk but any other future votes uh
i think i'm introducing one of the
motion and i would request a vote on
that one and i thank the clerk
and uh and the uh speaker pro tem for
the commentary
thank you mr speaker uh madam vice chair
the motion passed
for motion passed
um five to four thank you um
mr clerk and should we move on now to
um requests for late drafting and
introduction
and representative baldassaro has his
hand up
representative baldassaro thank you
i i actually i hit i did it by the way
it was close i had to raise the end
i had a question here i'm a little
confused on it i know we already caught
the vote
but can somebody tell me why i mean my
14th is my 14th year
why all of a sudden no committee
conferences why that was
pushed aside i know dick hints explained
it
to the caucus and i had to get up when
he was speaking at that
but i'd like to hear why all of a sudden
we got rid of
oh yeah
there's shirtless would you like to yeah
representative leader hinch if he wants
to explain to
uh the member what was said in their
caucus but i'd be glad to
answer it as best i can as we know we're
trying to finish up on business in the
new hampshire house
as well as the senate by a normal
deadline of june 30th
because of the pandemic we're trying to
reduce meetings as much as we can i'm
very proud of the new hampshire house we
have had over a dozen committee meetings
that have
exact over 30 bills but we all know
the uh tremendous workload it puts on
our outstanding
house staff as well as members
in an agreement with the senate
president to
expedite the finishing of our business
we are requesting that we not entered
any committees a conference
because of the pandemic and the
emergency orders which we are all
operating under in an order for us to
finish our
session by the june 30th deadline
that's the best i can do and if the
member has a follow-up i'd be glad to
answer it if i can
i do have a phone the reason why this
virtual stuff like i'll give you an
example yesterday
we had veterans call in but because they
didn't get the calendar
and they didn't have the information to
uh register
they couldn't speak now if they were in
a room
they could have put the gut up and
filled out a card and submitted it
so and then i homeless veterans on the
phone no way of raising their hand
uh then all of a sudden near the end
they said press star nine
but they already got aggravated and hung
up so this virtual thing would
we're stepping on the private on the
citizens right
to speak because not everyone has email
nobody sees the calendar and i'm hoping
we can get this
corrected and that's why i was shocked
about the comedic conferences also
with the excuse that we're in a pandemic
when
people are meeting all over the place
out there meeting on the streets
why yes as legislators are scared
well i if i may madam chain yes follow
i thank the member for his comment i
sent an email this morning to the chair
of the child of family law
recommending representative long for the
outstanding job
he did in conducting uh that committee
hearing yesterday at public hearing it's
my understanding over 15 people had an
opportunity to speak
uh in support of the bill that
representative baldassaro
um introduced that being a late bill
but a bill that remember felt had merit
and a reason for its lateness
um we are operating uh
our house staff is operating as is the
legislature the house itself
under our 91a our uh right to know law
we are following our house rules as
as far as i know this is the first
complaint that i've heard of anybody not
being able to
uh interact with the committee hearing
[Music]
i'm sorry if members didn't know if
individuals did not have an opportunity
to speak every hearing that is done
via a video link is also made available
to the public via
a telephonic link so they can call in as
well
this is posted in the calendar the
methodology to
access the meeting and we recently sent
out
rules to as to members who wish to speak
what that procedure is but also keeping
in mind the security of the link itself
so if anybody from the public did not
have a chance to speak
i would extend an apology to my friend
from londonderry but
uh uh everything that we have done we've
done under the rules of the house and
under
uh rsa 91a thank you madam chair
yes thank you mr speaker and let's move
on
uh i think at this point if you'd like
to move on madam chair i'll i'll just
take my hand down so
yes let's let's move on to the late
drafting
and the uh first item up is uh
again speaker shirtless and i believe
it's um you have
the drafting of a constitutional
amendment
thank you madam chair madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
my name is steve shirtless
and i represent merrimack district 11
which is ward 1 of the city of concord
the village of penacook
and i come before the rules committee
this morning to ask for the
permission for introduction and late
drafting
of a constitutional amendment concurrent
resolution
commonly referred to as the cacr
uh madam chair i became the speaker of
the house on december 5th
1918. thank you don't i i feel like in
2018 and uh at that
that time right after the first world
war i uh took over
um at that time in all seriousness my
chair
i never thought i'd see the day when the
new hampshire house of representatives
would not be able to meet in their
historic chambers where we have been
meeting since
1819 and on one occasion
as a new hampshire house met at an
alternative location
that was in 1864 when the new hampshire
house met
at the merrimack county courthouse
because the house itself was under major
renovations but at that meeting the
house was very able to meet together
um under our constitutional amendment
part two article 20 of the new hampshire
constitution
members of the new hampshire house are
required to be president
in the chamber to vote uh we are working
very extensively now
to hold a session on
june 11th at the whittemore center at
the university of new hampshire
people can only imagine the holistics
involved in getting 400 members of the
new hampshire house
in one chamber make sure that they are
distance
and all efforts are made to maintain and
protect their health safety
and public welfare in
19 on december 7th 1941 the new
hampshire
uh the united states was attacked upon
pearl harbor and the following day the
united states declared war on japan
and on the axis powers as a result of
that the new hampshire legislature
passed
an amendment to article 5 of the new
hampshire constitution
and that is titled continuity of
government in case of enemy attack
in this article of the new hampshire
constitution
we have the ability to meet at a
different location and meet remotely
in the event as the article says
resulting from disasters and caused by
an enemy
enemy attack now realizing how important
it is
primarily for the health and welfare of
members of the new hampshire house
that we do need a mechanism to
allow the new hampshire house to meet uh
online
in remotely at remote locations um
i introduce this amendment to article
five
dash a um in consultation with the clerk
and with the council for the house uh
it has been realized that the simplest
thing for us to do
in this article 5a uh constitutional
amendment
to strike out the words resulting from
disasters caused by enemy attacks
what this would do would be allowed the
new hampshire house when in
when we are in a national emergency or
in a statewide emergency declared by
either the president
president or the governor respectively
to meet remotely and to
[Music]
not be present at a meeting like we will
be doing
in in durham on the 11th
so um madam chair i if the committee has
any questions i'd be glad to answer them
again this bill is filed late because
just a matter of a few months ago we
never
thought there would be a need for the
new hampshire household representative
to meet remotely and not be together
in representatives hall and i asked the
the committee to support this uh late
drafting
and i'd be glad to answer your questions
i think i see representative hinch has
his hand up
am i right you are thank you madam chair
um and and i thank the speaker for his
um
um presentation on this uh for the
record
um i just want to state uh this may or
may not be
a good um amendment uh to the
constitution
i don't know um i understand the genesis
of why this is coming forward i have to
for the record though
um make sure that i uh am clear in
saying that whenever we
make an amendment to the constitution
it should be done with a very
very vigorous vetting and
as we talked about yesterday mr speaker
with the business taxes
that you're not going to support the
this amendment coming forward
is going to be expedited through
rushed through without a good
thorough public hearing the constitution
is one of the most if not the most uh
critical documents that we have in front
of us and to expedite a process
just to make it to the november ballot
may not be a wise
road for us to travel i haven't made
a decision whether i will support this
on the floor or not
i just want to let you know that i have
grave concerns
about bringing this forward in an
expedited fashion
and not allowing uh good thorough public
uh and private input into the cause and
effect of this
thank you thank you further discussion
do we have a motivation representative
representative um weber i move the
adoption of
the cac the uh i move the
approval of late drafting for the uh
motion
for this second the motion the second
the motion
moves and represents evil seconds the
motion
of uh allowing for late drafting further
discussion on the motion
seeing none do we have anyone on the
phone that
paul anyone
the committee um is is
uh everybody's lined up here they're the
the only
folks here there are several folks that
are on the phone but we typically don't
invite
okay so i will ask the clerk to call the
role
yes walnut yes
weber yes lay
yes evil yes
butler yes inch
no packard no
no well the sorrow
no
the motion uh for late drafting and
introduction
of a cacr is approved by a vote of six
to four
and mr speaker uh um uh
mr alakonis from the office of
legislative services is online
um and we can touch base with him later
in the day for
um that late drafting thank you mr clerk
and
thank you motion passes i'm gonna give
you
okay it's always a
tough act following the member from
concord representative wallner she has
done such an excellent job
um and i thank her for filling in now
um we're still hearing requests for late
drafting and introduction the chair
uh recognizes representative hinch
for a motion thank you mr speaker and
members of the committee
the proposal i would like the committee
to consider today is a simple but
incredibly
meaningful step to address our economic
recovery
new hampshire businesses of all sizes
are facing unprecedented
losses as a result of the current public
health crisis
we have the ability to ease the future
burden
on our state's job creators by
addressing the business tax rate
triggers
in current law according to reports from
the department of revenue administration
over 40 000 business entities in new
hampshire
pay one or both of our state's business
taxes
between 30 and 40 000 businesses pay the
business enterprise tax
which comes even if they are not
profitable
if we do nothing and the trigger is
activated the bet
rate will rise by 12 and a half percent
on january 1st as a tax on on business
payrolls
and if our goal to get people back to
work
it is critical that we alleviate this
future burden
now i've read the news and i've heard it
direct from the speaker
and the majority leader that they
believe this is not urgent
and can wait until 2021. my message
is that we cannot wait our businesses
cannot wait
the rate uh is scheduled to change on
january 1st
well before legislation could be
fast-tracked through the house and
senate
businesses are making decisions now and
will be through the rest of the year
based on the prospect of that rate
change
this affects their hiring decisions this
year
this affects their ability to purchase
capital equipment
this year etc to ask businesses to wait
and see quote unquote if the legislature
does something
in six months does not seem to make
sense
the january rate tax rate is already
affecting the decision-making now
not allowing this simple modification to
have an up or down vote
by the house is the same thing as as
saying you are okay
with increased taxes on our struggling
small businesses during a global
pandemic
and economic recovery this is not
a dramatic change in policy this would
simply keep the rates
where they are now into the new year
this is not rocket science
it's a way to demonstrate that the
legislature is focused
on jobs and the economy and we want to
help
our small businesses rise out of this
pandemic the time is now to act on this
urgent need for our businesses to know
their taxes
will not go up and they can get our
citizens back to work
thank you mr speaker
are there any questions for leader hinch
or any comments on the
proposed motion
representative has his hand up mr
speaker the chair recognizes the
representative baldur
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i have
to concur with our representative dick
hinch
and the reason why i have a long time
friend here has been in business in
londonderry for about 10 years
okay and they're not opening the doors
anymore
i was told yesterday that we have some
businesses on 102.
there's moving trucks over there packing
their up packing them up
they kid they can't they can't sustain
the business anymore
they're closing down this i this i'm in
londonderry
you know a well-to-do town this must be
happening all over the state by if we
don't
take the extra step now and stop this so
they can plan their budgets for january
we got problems uh we're gonna have a
lot of bankruptcies in the state of new
hampshire
i'll leave it at that thank you thank
you representative
any further comments or questions mr
speaker representative wallner has her
hand up representative walden is
recognized
hope she's muted unmute her i'm sorry
unmute okay can you hear me now yeah
i'm sorry about that your record thank
you mr speaker
when i think about the late drafting
i always try to consider whether or not
uh the drafting uh pertains to
information that is
completely new to the situation
and actually the triggers have been in
the budget
since we passed it in september so we
were all
we've all been aware of the um
the triggers that were in the budget and
how those triggers work
we're now in june so we've had a lot of
time to think about them
and to have uh brought forth in the
regular
um session we could have brought forth
legislation to change those
those triggers so um for me
it does not feel like um this is the
time
for us to be changing um
what we voted on in the budget in
september
and um as
all of you know the governor has
um allowed businesses to pay taxes
that were due in april they will be in
um the date has been
pushed up to june 15th which was a
i think a good a good good choice to
push that data
but at this point we don't really have
the kind of information we need
to make this kind of a decision so uh
for me i'll be voting no
on the motion um for uh late drafting
thank you mr speaker representative
hinch had his hand up and then
representative hosel
representative hinch is recognized thank
you mr speaker i would just like to
remind everybody that is participating
here today
that the pandemic occurred during
uh the month of march and this is urgent
and compelling at this time was
unforeseen at the time
that the budget was negotiated and
passed and put into law
so this is this is something to address
the pandemic and to help the businesses
that are suffering and going out of
business this is not something
that could have been foreseen back in
december
or earlier when we did the budget thank
you
representative holzel is recognized
thank you uh i guess i would
repeat exactly what representative hinch
just said but also i'm from a community
that the business all of the businesses
are struggling at this point and
i've heard from many of them
i cannot vote uh in favor of this
thank you uh any other questions
representative lay mr speaker
representative lay is recognized i think
representative weber had her hand up
before him
uh actually you did because you went to
the top of the list
okay
well thank you mr speaker um i would
just point out that um
while the pandemic began in march um
this trigger was put in place in
september and it was certainly
understood by everybody including the
governor who proposed the trigger
it was certainly understood that the
only way this trigger would come into
effect would be
in a serious circumstances
those circumstances have arisen so
therefore there is nothing new here
um except that it has
actually has come to pass so
i don't see anything new that is
developed here
more to the point in what i did state
the other day
right now we do not know what the
state's revenues will be
for the fiscal year we also don't know
what the business tax revenues will be
for the fiscal year
and this will be determined as stated in
the budget agreement
ultimately by the kafir which comes out
in december of 2020
at that point we would have much more
information in terms of
the overall status of state
budgetary revenues and we would also
have much more information
obviously upon the state of business tax
revenues and i think that on something
such as this
because it'll have a major impact on the
second year second fiscal year of the
biennium and also
on future budgets and future bienniums
that it simply makes sense
to wait until we have the full
information at hand right now we do not
have it
and so to make fiscal policy
without adequate fiscal and financial
information is akin to planning on the
back of a napkin
and we should not be engaging in that
sort of planning
and that sort of policy making therefore
i must vote against the proposal
offered by my friend representative
hinch thank you
thank you representative weber mr
speaker representative webb is
recognized
thank you mr speaker i
much of what i was going to say has
already been stated
by representative lay so i won't restate
it except to say that although we did
not
anticipate a pandemic this particular
catastrophe we certainly did
and have for years when we've been
discussing triggers
recognized that one of the things that
might happen
is a significant economic disruption
and that's what we're looking at now i
also want to make it
clear from my perspective that
i absolutely agree that we have many
many businesses that are in terrible
dire straits
but i think it very unlikely that for
those businesses in dire straits that
the change in the business
tax rates that we are talking about here
is going to make a material difference
to whether they stay open
or not because there are so many other
stressors
that are so much more dire for those
businesses
and i also want to remind all of us that
there are
any number of very large out of state
do i need to stop sir uh just just for a
moment i'm not sure why the recording
was stopped
we're all set
okay good uh my last point was just that
we have
many large out-of-state corporations who
as a result of this pandemic are doing
far better than they have ever done
before and
as representative lay said it is
important for us to understand
exactly who is benefiting and who is
who is going to actually be affected in
their business plans by the rate change
so i thank you very much for the
opportunity to comment
mr speaker representative holzel has her
hand up again
representative holzel is recognized
thank you mr speaker i
i misspoke and because i didn't know
exactly what the
motion would be but i am
fully in favor of this motion
and i think it will help the little
business
and we need to keep them around thank
you
i thank the member for the correction
any other questions or comments
mr speaker representative hinch had his
hand up and then representative butler
and i would just make a quick mention mr
speaker one of the members accidentally
hit um on their computer or tablet the
um pause recording button and that's uh
what caused the interruption so
so please just be mindful of uh
no comment um
representative uh i'm sorry mr clerk uh
i know representative butler
you mentioned it was before
representative hinch uh
representative that's what i thought
representative hinch was
yeah thank you mr speaker and not i'm mo
prolong this because i know where the
vote's going to go
but in um conclusion i would just like
to point out
that this proposal is absolutely not
being done
on the back of a napkin but failure to
act on this
will be on the backs of the businesses
that will definitely go out of business
from our lack of action on this so thank
you
thank you representative butler is
recognized
a small business owner i just want to
reinforce uh what uh especially
representative weber said um the impact
of this tax
will be minimal if felt at all
by my business and many other small
businesses
and having all of the information
necessary
to understand the impact i think is
critically important
and so therefore i will not be
supporting
the motion um
are there any other questions or
comments
we currently don't have a motion before
us is there a motion
on representative hinch's request
like representative baldessaro yeah i'd
like to make a motion that we support
representative dick inches um request
representative baldessaro moves so we
accept the request for the late drafting
introduction as that second did
uh representative packard is muted but
he's moving his mouth let me unmute him
okay i second it okay
um the motion is seconded the motion
before the house
is the um
is the adoption of the request by
representative hinch for the late
drafting
and introduction of this bill dealing
with business taxes
uh are we ready for the question uh
other any other comment
seeing none i would ask the clerk to
call the role
currently no walnut
no weber no
lay no evil
no butler
no inch yes
packard yes also
yes sorrow yes
the motion fails four to six
the motion has failed the motion ought
to pass is
fails four to six is there another
motion
i'll i'll move in expedient to move
forward with this
is that seconded a second representative
weber moves representative waldner
seconds the motion that
the request is inexpedient to legislate
is there any comment seeing that i asked
the clerk to call the role
thank you mr speaker the uh the question
is to not
allow for late drafting introduction um
shirtless yes
walnur yes
uh weber yes lay
yes evil yes
butler yes
inch no
hackard no ozil
no all the sorrow no
the motion to not introduce
um and allow for late drafting is
adopted
six to four mr speaker thank you mr
clerk just for the identification of
those at home
uh incorrect me if i'm wrong the member
does have the right to bring that
request before the full house on the
introduction of this bill
uh yes speaker on on the floor of the
house
representative hinch or any other member
could move um
for uh the suspension of rules for
late drafting introduction uh referral
from committee et cetera et cetera
i thank the clerk just for those that
are watching they'll know
what the process is mr speaker
representative hinton
has his hand up representative hench is
recognized
thank you mr speaker just so no one's
surprised i will be breaking
bringing a motion forward to the floor
i think it's nobody's surprise i thank
the leader i have thankfully your first
comments
uh mr mr speaker i'm going to move
representative prout
um up from the attendee to
uh the panel for a
request okay the last business before
the committee uh other than other
business
is a request by representative andrew
prout to bring in a late
a request for late drafting and
introduction of a bill
and representative proud is recognized
thank you mr speaker i am representative
andrew prout
sorry uh thank you mr speaker i am
representing andrew prout representing
hillsborough
uh county district number 37 the towns
of hudson and pelham
back in march i coordinated the issuance
of a press release by a bipartisan group
of legislators calling on the governor
to temporary allow bars and restaurants
to be allowed to fill growlers
during the state of emergency growlers
are a refillable beer container
usually made of glass and are very
common in the craft brewing industry
they are refilled from beer tabs very
similar to pouring a pint for immediate
consumption
but are then sealed and transported the
filling of growlers
breweries has continued unaffected
throughout the shutdown
this request was made in the hopes that
to solve a looming problem
draft beer in kegs has a very short
shelf life
unlike bottle or canned beer domestic
cake beer is mostly unpasteurized
the problem identified back in march is
that if the restaurant shutdown lasted
any significant period
of time the beer and kegs already in
restaurant inventory would spoil
in this press release i promised to do
whatever i could to prevent this
including late introduction into the
current term
and so here we are unfortunately it's
been a while since march
the beer in inventory back then has
spoiled by now
i've heard from one restaurant owner of
a five-figure losses from
spoiled beer and that's even before
disposal fees
spoiled beer cannot simply pour down the
drain in such volumes without
negatively affecting septic systems or
sewage treatment plants
so the disposal itself has become a
challenge as well
however i still want to file the bill
while i sincerely hope it does not
happen many experts are concerned about
a seasonal resurgence of
the kovic 19 virus in the fall if that
happens i want allowances to be in place
for restaurants to be allowed to sell
their existing inventory
of keg beer if there's a new shutdown
order or on in-person dining the
language i envisioned for this bill
would do two things
permit filling of growers with labels
not matching the product within them
this is currently prohibited as a
misbranding of beer
however this is not a major concern in
this context the growler owner
the caller is owned by the consumer they
bring it in and request to be filled
with a specific product on the spot
the selling of pre-filled growlers is
just not done
additionally most established students
are prepared to fix a temporary label or
tag
on during each fill and the second thing
is permit
on-premise license holders facing a
shutdown or significant drop in volume
due to a state of emergency
to sell their existing inventory of keg
beer
in refillable containers under the same
regulations as breweries
these two points go hand in hand as most
breweries sell
separately empty growlers with their
brand logo i cannot expect
restaurants to do the same just in case
of a shutdown
thank you mr speaker and i'd be happy to
take any of the committee's questions
i thank the member are there any
questions for representative prout or
any comments
uh yes mr speaker representative hinch
had his hand up and represent baldur
sarah has his hand up
representative hinch is recognized thank
you mr speaker i just wanted for the
record to indicate that i'm in
support full support um of the late
drafting uh that
uh representative proud is bringing
forward i thank the member
representative baldessaro is recognized
thank you mr speaker mr speaker for
andrew
representative prout i i seen pictures
of
a uh borrowing in manchester in concord
with over ten thousand dollars worth of
uh kegs
that have been outdated and couldn't
sell have you seen
many other restaurants with the same
issue
uh with this beer that they had to get
rid of i don't know how they dispose of
it
um throughout the state
uh i have been hearing throughout the
state and throughout the country of
other restaurants with similar issues
and
trying to find creative ways to dispose
of it to turn it in
to reprocess it into animal feed or hand
sanitizer or do something with it
like i said it's actually quite a
challenge to dispose of it in that
volume
without uh you know environmental or
other effects on the existing
disposal options
any other questions or comments mr
speaker representative butler has his
hand up
chair recognizes representative butler
thank you mr speaker
uh representative prout uh help me to
understand
um the uh
the how this bill would proceed um
and whether or not it is just for the
uh pandemic and the emergency order
um i guess that's my first question will
this only be
during the period of the uh emergency
order
so the language i envisioned uh point
one of permitting the
growlers to be filled contrary to their
the printed logo
on them that i had a vision just being a
permanent thing because
it's uh it hasn't been something that
has made a whole lot of sense because as
i said the growlers normally owned by
the consumer
they walk into a brewery currently and
requested to be filled with a specific
product
the fact that it's prohibited under our
current law for as a misbranding
to protect consumers a consumer
protection accident hasn't made a whole
lot of sense to
anyone who's looked at that i've spoken
to the second point would only be during
a state of emergency
that either does a complete shutdown or
significant
reduction in volume to
the uh the sale of beer and so that they
could sell it in an
alternative manner in growlers
in representative butler did you have a
follow-up question
i do thank you um relative to the
labeling issue
um as you know the commerce committees
at least in the house deal with the
issue of our alcohol bills and
statutes and we have looked at and dealt
with growler
issues over the past few years
and the house indeed has supported the
use
of growlers and extension of growlers
in ways that
will be consistent with how the liquor
commission
um is uh willing and able to support it
so i'm concerned about the labeling
issue um
and uh i would want to see that
uh come before the legislative body
and to determine how to deal with that
rather than
uh make a decision relative uh to that
piece
um with a late drafting
bill that hasn't had a chance to really
be vetted
so that concerns me the rest of the bill
seems to make sense
representative prout did you wish to
comment
certainly uh i mean i was trying to be
the most expedient if it uh
would uh make the committee more
favorable to build i certainly could add
attach the state of emergency language
to that aspect of the
point number one of what i was proposing
as well
thank you thank you representatives for
other questions and representatives
and representative have their hands on
mr speaker
representative lee is recognized thank
you mr speaker um
i just had a uh actually two questions
one for the representative and one for
the uh the chair for the speaker
uh representative prout
i i think if i heard you correctly you
said this would take
effect or this is to be effective in a
state of emergency
and then i i thought i heard you say or
at a time when there is a significant
reduction
in the sale of beer
i i'm just trying to i may have misheard
you on that i'm just trying to clarify
for myself here what
when what would be the circumstances
that you envisioned that this would take
effect
um or that this would be in effect
you criteria two criteria the criteria
one is this there's a state of emergency
and criteria two that that state of
emergency has either caused a complete
closure
or a significant reduction of volume
okay so the reduction in volume
uh in your uh proposal would be due to
the state of emergency
not just for example the fact that
people just don't want to drink
x brand any longer and just don't feel
like buying it
correct what i'm thinking here is if
restaurants are open for
25 of normal capacity clearly they won't
be able to sell the same volume of beer
okay thank you um and then mr speaker
under the current rules as they stand
could the house consider an act on this
bill
um given that the current rules state
that um all house bills need to be acted
on
by i think uh uh well second committee
bills needed to be acted on by
a date set in march
well that's somewhat of a catch-22 let
me ask the clerk
mr clerk if we do not have the deadlines
in place could this
be brought in as a late bill
the the short answer is is yes mr
speaker uh similar to your cacr
um situation is that uh
your um your committee today can allow
for late drafting and introduction only
it cannot
supersede um the other rules of the
house
so in order to act on them when the full
house comes together it would still
require two-thirds suspension
um for all of the other rules regarding
public hearings
referral committee etc etc um
but um it's that is still possible um
under under those scenarios uh we can um
you know we could when the house comes
together on the 11th
um take up every piece of legislation
with a two-thirds suspension
minus um uh deadlines to do that
yeah good thanks a brief follow-up
mr speaker so if
for example on this bill um the house
voted by a two-thirds margin to suspend
the rules to allow
i haven't touched a thing
okay thank you uh
so if um the house were to take up this
bill vote to suspend rules to take up
this bill
does the bill need to pass by a
two-thirds vote or is it a simple
majority then
so so if we suspend all rules uh
regarding um
everything to get to this point um then
no it would not require two-thirds
okay it would it would simply require a
majority
um having suspended all um relevant
rules
okay thank you
further questions or comments uh
representative baldassaro and
representative butler have their hands
up mr speaker
representative baldsar was recognized mr
speaker thank you
mr speaker this bill here coming forward
is a win-win
it goes in accordance with the rules
committee there because who knew we were
going to have a pandemic
the growlers that he talks about will
help
the many many breweries throughout the
state because this is attracting our
young
back to our state as we've been our
numbers have been going up
i heard earlier somebody said that it
wasn't it would not be
properly vetted but it's okay to not
properly vet this bill
but the constitution amendment is okay
no big deal
so i'm hoping that we come together and
you know let's support this and move
forward and let the representatives
speak for it thank you
thank you representative butler
thank you mr speaker uh understanding
that the labeling piece of the bill
will be within the executive order
period i will support
the late drafting
okay any other questions or comments
is there a motion
representative has his hand up and
representative hinch has his hand up
we support the late drafting of
representative proud's bill
representative balsaro moves the late uh
the approval of the late drafting of
representative proud
bill and representative hinge second
the motion is seconded the question
before the committee now
is the motion to accept the late uh
drafting
of representative proud's bill dealing
with growlers
are you ready for the question any other
comments
seeing then i would ask the clerk to
call the role
shirtless yes walner
yes weber yes
lay yes evil
yes butler yes
inch yes packard
yes
yes yes
motion passes 10 to zero mr speaker and
if i may uh representative proutz
um if you could please email today that
ask
ols legg.state.nh.us
email address with your information so
that we can get it
printed as fast as possible
i'll do that and thank you to the
committee for your approval thank you
representative prout
and uh with a vote of 10 to nothing it's
good to see the bipartisanship is alive
and well
in the new hampshire house and so we'll
now
now move on to other business by the
speaker beer
i want a growler are there any other
business to come before this committee
scene then the committee will be in
recess to the call of the chair
mr clerk do you have any additional
final comments
uh no sir uh thank you all for your your
hard work today
thank you and again i want to thank our
house staff who have done such a
marvelous job of
putting this committee meeting together
and and as always i thank the clerk and
thank all of you
bye-bye thank you thank you